i want to talk through uh kind of
various assets i'll just kind of throw
out you know kind of a corner of the
industry uh or one of the main assets in
the industry you just riff on you know
kind of your current thoughts of them so
let's start with bitcoin as kind of the
largest uh market cap asset where do you
think we are with bitcoin with adoption
and kind of from a market structure
standpoint
so
bitcoin from a market structure has been
incredibly bullish the pattern now you
know the chart pattern looks very
similar to a smaller version of the one
from march to june 2020 uh where it
exploded we've had this lovely
corrective phase we see all the
unchanged stuff you know william
clements show you know
and will he win all those guys showing
that it's all going into good strong
hands
we had the china fudd we've had a bunch
of fun
this usually and there's no guarantees
usually october november december is
ridiculously good particularly at this
point in the halving cycle so
structure it looks amazing so okay who
are the buyers here so most people who
got into crypto
came in via bitcoin that's always the
case it's the it's the big daddy asset
and then people move out the risk curve
and that's pretty normal
so who's the next big bar of bitcoin
it's pretty clear to me who they are it
is the ongoing institutions i mean that
just keeps going and i think we'll set
an acceleration in that particularly if
the price breaks out because everybody's
like sheep they always want to follow
each other
secondly it is the the coming etf it's
definitely gonna well definitely i don't
know that but i just have a very strong
feeling it comes in the next you know
over this october november december
period and that will drive a huge amount
of money in the space because it allows
raas to allocate and ordinary
individuals in a way that they can
easily understand
and finally i think
we're starting to see noise from the
sovereign wealth funds so i know some of
them and i've talked about this before
with you is some of them already
allocated but i think we're going to
start to see more sovereign wealth
activity in the space
ethereum and in the ether asset
so ethereum um again the charts look
absolutely astonishing the on-chain
activity the adoption is is
by far the largest of anything in the
space um so it's huge what's going on
the move towards 2.0 means that you know
at a simple level everybody's going to
stake everything they've got to get it
there and so that takes all the coins
off the market there's about 11 of all
ethan circulation so it's almost
unbuyable so you bring a whale into the
market the price just explodes so i've
never really seen a setup as good as
this um in that respect so
i think it's it's it's a very high
quality bet for the time being because
of all of this stuff that's either off
exchange being staked and there's no
free supply and demand keeps going
exponential
so um i like keith overall what's
interesting is to start to see
institutional adoption
so i spoke at um cowan's big event and
it wasn't about bitcoin it was solely
about ethereum which took me by surprise
that's the first one i've done
it's kind of been referenced in other
ones but here i am now speaking to
investment banks when they're asking me
to come and talk about ethereum and just
skipping bitcoin saying well we assume
you know bitcoin but here's another
opportunity so i think there's a lot
more adoption to come in that space and
i think there's going to be etf there
too and again with this
really restricted supply that's going on
because of ether 2.0 i think it drives
prices a lot when you think about the
institutions uh that are thinking about
or talking about ethereum and ether is
it because they've already allocated to
bitcoin or do you see some of them
coming in and they're basically actually
skipping over bitcoin
you know um i think there are some that
are skipping over bitcoin because they
get their head around it in a different
way because they think of it as a way of
playing the entire technology of the
space
um so then they don't
you know it's hard for many of these
institutions to stomach the narrative
the bitcoin narrative of a store of
value that central banks are destroying
the world and a lot of this stuff
because that kind of goes against a bit
of their business model
but ethereum is not as
um
it doesn't feel like it's attacking them
as much because it's like here's a space
and we're building decentralized finance
on it and and you know everybody can be
participate um it doesn't feel that they
have to change their internal narratives
some are finding it just a bit easier to
get their heads around what it is
without kind of going against or kind of
exposing the wizard of oz which is the
central banks and what they're doing to
currencies overall
let's talk about uh what i'll call
ethereum competitors maybe some of them
aren't necessarily competitive they're
they're more complementary but uh like
the smart contract platform so this is
uh polka dot this is solana
and there's kind of a whole group of
those that are out there how do you look
at those assets
um so all i do is look at adoption
effects because i'm not smart enough to
figure out what change is better than
what and who why they want to build on
it etc etc but interestingly as i've
mentioned before
ethereum is exactly following i mean
exactly following bitcoin in 2017 in
both price and price structure
bitcoin is following bitcoin 2013 which
is fascinating um in price structure but
not in price itself um you know and then
what so i thought you know what i bet
you solano is following um ethereum in
2017 if anybody was in that market at
that time ethereum was the rocket ship
that took everybody by surprise and
guess what
it's exact chart fit
and the prices are the same so ethereum
so solana is exactly following um
ethereum theorems exactly following
bitcoin it's like the magic is all in
this network adoption and it kind of all
makes sense
the other two that are in that
kind of fast growth fast adoption page
phase where you see exponential price
rises more than anything else
is obviously terror um probably
avalanche and probably um
[Music]
polka dots and i think you know they
will all do well in this cycle and like
ethereum they'll all go down a lot later
um and then from that we'll see how it
builds out but it kind of it's bizarrely
consistent i never thought this would be
the case because you see all the people
online it's like my project my project
but when you net balance it all out and
just apply like adoption effects and do
these things look similar they're almost
identical which is amazing